whoo
we still got a lot to talk about hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by cosmic
crisp washington apples and we are back
with part four of our review of jaclyn
hills weight loss series
she is on this crazy diet right now
where she's eating only vegetables
literally only vegetables oh my god look
at the difference look at the difference
in my face with the difference
that just
diet can make it already smells so
good you guys all i've had today is two
eggs and vegetables it's about six
o'clock right now i'm a little shocked
by how good it is and it's really just
veggies and shrimp i'm officially 13
pounds down which is crazy i've
literally turned into what i hate
because i'm like stop people shouldn't
be obsessing over the scale like focus
on the way you feel focus on the way you
look focused on the way your jeans are
fitting and i'm like addicted to the
scale now and it's like ruining my mood
i'm just like
what is this but first let me drop in
here to tell you about my sponsor cosmic
crisp apples so little known abby
factoid my nickname growing up was abby
appleseed because my mom said i want to
eat apples every meal and snack not much
has changed so if you are apple obsessed
like me you will love my new go-to
cosmic crisp washington apples i am all
about a good crisp apple like if it's
mealy i don't want it and these apples
are super crispy and much sweeter than
other varieties plus they are naturally
slower to brown and that is key for me
because my kids basically take two bites
of an apple and then leave it on the
counter and if it's brown by the time
they get back they want a whole fresh
one so these are officially the apples
of motherhood as far as i'm concerned so
for a little background these apples
were classically bred at washington
state university and are naturally
non-gmo they taste like a hybrid between
the enterprise and the honey crisp
varieties and they are perfect for
snacking cooking or baking we are
currently putting them in just about
everything over here so if you want to
try out cosmic crisp apples yourself
check out my link to learn more and you
can pause the screen or look at the
description or check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always please
feel free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and of course
if you are new here do not forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
bell so that you never miss out on an
episode and if you're not already
definitely head on over to instagram and
tick tock to follow me there at abby's
kitchen if you've been following along
with our review of jaclyn's series and
missed out on our last episodes you can
check them out right here but as a quick
recap i discussed some of my thoughts on
some of the overarching themes that have
stood out throughout jacqueline's
journey and whether or not i feel that
they're supportive to her goals and her
relationship with food now i realized
that i filmed these way in advance so
there's actually likely a lot more
videos in the series since this came out
but there's a lot to unpack in like
every single video so i want to share my
thoughts on her november 1st video today
why am i gaining weight let's take a
look i had a small protein shake for
breakfast and then i had a snack which
was a piece of string cheese and some
almonds jordan is making chicken and
rice and i cannot wait it smells so good
it's a chicken piccata it's like my
favorite recipe we make it probably like
once or twice a week at this point i'll
show you the beauty when he's done my
guide puts lemon chicken piccata with
basmati rice arrowroot starch instead of
flour
eating healthy can be amazing so first
of all i am disappointed that she's gone
all day with basically just a small
snack like that is typically a set up
for a binge so i would really love to
see some more regular meal spacing here
but i do want to give the girl props on
her dinner here let's just take a moment
to think back to when i first reviewed
jaclyn's diet in my video right here
like the girls seemed to exclusively
live off chicken and vegetables and
quite frankly hated it there was no joy
no satisfaction no carbs just pure
obligatory eating for the sake of her
diet but this
seems to be something she genuinely
loves like it's not a cheat it's not low
carb and it's not good or bad it's just
chicken piccata made by her bow with
love now of course to really optimize
this meal as my hunger crushing combo
and bulk it up for the satiety factor i
would definitely throw in a side of
veggies but otherwise it looks delish is
it a substantial enough meal after
basically not eating all day i would say
not but the way that this video runs
it's not like a what in a day so i have
really no idea what she's eating later
on in the night to make up for it as for
her comment that the arrow powder is
kind of healthier than regular flour i
mean the term healthier is so subjective
arrow has about the same amount of
calories and marginally more fiber but
significantly less protein and more
carbs than all-purpose flour now it is
however gluten-free and if that's
something that feels better for jaclyn
then yes it could be healthier for her i
don't think it needs a label i'm just
excited to see her find foods that feel
better for her digestion and energy
levels rather than just choosing foods
because they are low cal and i'm also
kind of hoping that if she did just get
a little busy and forget to eat all day
that there were some more snacks later
on to make up for it guests will never
know we came home so starving we were so
hungry that we just ate this we got um
tuna poke it's ahi tuna and we've just
been eating it with seaweed chips
avocado and sriracha okay so again there
seems to be a lot of scenarios where
we're forgetting to eat or we're letting
ourselves get super super hungry when we
don't have a meal prepared which often
is a recipe for overeating but i will
say that for a meal thrown together
while ravenous this looks pretty awesome
awesome and also super satisfying you
know with all the protein and healthy
fats in there from the tuna plus the fat
and fiber in the avocado i mean most of
us like bust into the chips on the car
ride home from the grocery store when
really hungry so this definitely does
look a lot more nutritious but i'd say
if she had a little more foresight and
wanted to make this like a solid meal
she could turn this into like a poke
bowl with some pre-cooked rice and then
any leftover veg that she maybe had in
the fridge i'm about to head over to my
mom's house and hang out for like an
hour
she is on this crazy diet right now
where she's eating only vegetables
literally only vegetables and like a
protein shake i mean
not to call anyone out but i'm pretty
sure are you sure about that that isn't
that different from what jaclyn was
doing earlier on in the start of this
journey just saying mom you guys let me
show you my breakfast so i
made ground turkey i put some cheese on
it and then a soft boiled egg while her
mom's veggie and protein shake diet is
obviously not sufficient and she knows
that herself i'm also worried that this
also has some glaring gaps mainly that
we've got no fiber no carbs and actually
no produce at all so we are missing out
on some vital micronutrients and
actually micronutrient deficiency is
surprisingly common in chronic dieters
one study on obese individuals found
that those on reduced calorie diets were
almost always micronutrient deficient so
i would definitely make sure to throw
some veggies into the stir fry when
she's cooking that up and then pair it
with a slice or two of whole grain toast
i have gotten so many tweets and texts
and dms from the friends family you guys
everybody just telling me how much
thinner my face has gotten haven't
really taken the time to like actually
notice it so i put like side-by-side
photos i just posted it on my instagram
but i got so choked out because i'm like
oh my god look at the difference first
of all i have no issue with aesthetic
goals so i am super happy for jacqueline
if she's feeling excited about the
progress that she can see in the mirror
but i just want to flag that there is a
difference between weight loss from
caloric restriction and also water
weight and inflammation related to food
choices so chronic inflammation from
excessive intake of sugar trans fats
omega-6 fats salt alcohol and processed
meat is generally seen in blood work as
it relates to chronic disease risk not
so much in your face there may be some
tissue inflammation from food
intolerances to something like gluten
but generally inflammation is an often
overused word in the wellness space and
is kind of used as a pc term for fat a
more likely explanation for this is just
like a reduction in edema water
retention or puffiness corresponding to
a reduction in salt carbohydrates and
also potentially alcohol it already
smells so
so good you guys i use bone broth also
nine grams of protein i cut up onions i
cut up celery carrots frozen green beans
i also used this frozen california blend
i used a couple bags of these and then i
did a giant handful of kale and i did
two cans of these diced tomatoes and
green chiles and then i did a ton of
fresh garlic um just squeeze that right
i added
shredded chicken in it i just bought a
rotisserie chicken okay while this
recipe originally came from jaclyn's
mom's super low cal all vegetable diet i
am so happy to see that she bumped up
the satisfaction and satiety factor by
using bone broth and also chicken for
the protein i also like that she was
inspired to make it at home not because
it was low calorie but because she tried
her mom's vegetable soup and said it
tasted amazing that's it no
dichotomizing language about whether the
soup was good or bad or diet friendly or
anti-inflammatory nada it was just tasty
as is and she knew how to make it even
more satisfying for her the end
okay maybe not the end i mean it is
still a relatively low calorie low fat
and low carb meal so ideally we would
want to add in like some pasta or maybe
serve it with some bread and olive oil
on the side but i'm happy to hear she's
starting to actually enjoy naturally
nourishing food and not feel the need to
like drag her through something
unsatisfying and super just local i'm
going to dinner tonight all i've had
today is two eggs and vegetables it's
about six o'clock right now yeah like
this is apparently a theme here and i
mean is this stop the same girl who just
shamed her mom for only eating
vegetables and like a protein shake i
don't know what that was one again under
eating in any circumstance is bad news
bears but it's especially dangerous
before a night of eating out generally
speaking any calories one saves in the
day are almost always immediately made
up for when you get to the table
starving and they set down that
delicious looking bread basket their
breadsticks are like crap i mean even if
it's not delicious when you're starving
you're gonna want to eat it all our real
friends eat we get four different pastas
yes and just with a sampler
so i have no clue exactly how much she
ate here it could have been a completely
normal amount of food and you should be
able to dine out even while dieting but
i'm seeing a pattern of not eating very
much in the day and then kind of saving
all her calories for that evening meal
which is not going to be great for
digestion and potentially especially
when you're eating out it's very easy to
undo any caloric deficit that you may
have set for yourself and this is really
no fault of hers i mean she's hungry as
you would be if you only had a snack all
day so food is going to taste
particularly good not that we need any
research to know this but we do have
evidence that caloric deprivation aka
being hungry increases taste sensitivity
to both sweet and salty foods which in
turn can result in overeating and that's
definitely what happens to me when i go
out to eat if i haven't had anything
substantial to eat all day leading up to
it making a spring roll something that i
saw on tik tok that looked so good
use rice paper i'm using shrimp peppers
is this a this is a green onion right i
always want to call it a chive a green
onion avocado lettuce cilantro carrots
rice noodles i'm a little shocked by how
good it is and it's literally just
veggies and shrimp this is so low in
calories this definitely is not enough
for me to eat for like a dinner i i need
more than this i do love this snack and
also that she just came out and called
it a snack even though it could
potentially be a meal if she had enough
of them i suppose but we got carbs and
the rice noodles fasten the avocado
protein in the shrimp and then lots of
fiber rich veg and again i'm just so
happy to hear jaclyn trying to plan
meals and snacks based on nutrient
adequacy and eating enough not just
getting by on as few calories as
possible i would love to see her adopt
this philosophy for some of the meals
and snacks earlier on in the day not
just for getting enough calories at
dinner i'm officially 13 pounds down
which is crazy and when i first started
this journey i was doing it just to get
healthy right but now like as weights
coming off of me i'm feeling so good
that i'm almost like on a weight loss
journey now that does that make sense
like first it was just i wanted to feel
good but now as i'm losing weight i'm
feeling so good that i want to lose more
weight i know his position as something
she was doing to feel better at the
start but then what was the point of
frequently getting on the scale like
what would her weight have to do with
her feeling better if that was indeed
the goal i i don't mean to call her out
but let's just be honest with ourselves
about our intentions here now on the
flip side again i have nothing against
weight loss goals but i am concerned
that when weight loss becomes the
primary goal and then weight loss
potentially stalls or reverses that we
risk losing motivation to continue
health promoting behaviors that
initially felt good for work today we
use the mission carb balance tortillas
just to do like turkey and salami
situation i have two hard boiled eggs
string cheese
and turkey pepperoni i'm so happy to see
her actually planning snacks as opposed
to just kind of forgetting to eat and
get really crazy and then only having
dinner and i agree it's always great to
have extra snacks just like in your back
pocket or in your purse bag
just prepped ready to go so that we can
make more mindful decisions about what
to eat and i get that maybe low carb
seems to be working for her but i would
still love to see some kind of veggies
or fruit in the mix here because
basically everything in that whole kind
of snack or meal pack is all pretty low
carb we're going out to a taco
restaurant i want to have like a pretty
good snack before we go that way when i
get there i'm able just to do something
like light and easy we just whipped up
some tuna right here and then we put on
sliced cucumbers
the girl like preemptively listened to
my advice this is great now that protein
and fat in there is definitely gonna
help take the edge off of her like
pre-dinner hunger so that way like she
said she can make more mindful decisions
at the restaurant something i feel like
is super frustrating that needs to be
talked about is i have come across a
couple of people in my life in the past
you know six weeks or so who literally
make fun of me for making good healthy
choices the other day i was with a group
of people and there was a snack there
that i really really really love but it
is so bad for you there's absolutely no
reason i need to be eating it right now
so there was somebody there who
literally was taunting me and like
grabbing the snack and being like um
aren't you jealous i'm just like
what is this so in my last video i
discussed some suggestions for asking
her partner jordan for support but it's
really too bad her friends are being
such immature dicks like if this is
something that you're struggling with
know that it's not a you problem it's a
them problem this is about their own
insecurities with food and their bodies
and if i was jaclyn if i want to
continue to see these friends i would
very respectfully say you know i'm
trying really hard to eat better and the
choices i'm making feel really good to
me and my body but you're making it
really hard for me to succeed on this
journey so if you want to enjoy insert
snack here go for it
but please don't tease me for my food
choices and if they honestly can't get
on board i would say just don't invite
them over like they sound like total to
me my scale has gone up two pounds in
the last two days and it's ridiculous
and it makes no sense because i lost 13
pounds doing this exact thing
i haven't been eating anything after
dinner low calories i've been putting
just good food in my body how can i go
up and wait it's so discouraging it
literally makes me want to quit jaclyn's
journey it makes me want to stop all of
this it's just like forget it let me
squeeze pizza then if i was going to be
putting on weight i've literally turned
into what i hate because i'm like stop
people shouldn't be obsessing over the
scale like focus on the way you feel
focus on the way you look focused on the
way your jeans are fitting and i'm like
addicted to the scale now and it's like
ruining my mood yeah um i really feel
for jaclyn right now and this is why i
don't love setting weight loss as your
primary goal and also why i don't love
frequent use of the scale because as she
said consistent linear weight loss is
not real life it's not a variable that
we can directly control the same way we
can directly control maybe our food
habits or our activity like there are a
lot of confounders at play so seeing a
two pound jump doesn't even suggest a
plateau necessarily what i do see here
is that the scale is a major trigger for
jaclyn and i worry that her obsession
with it an investment in it may be a
catalyst for landing her right back at
square one like it puts you in a very
black and white mindset of well if i'm
not losing i might as well be gaining
which then triggers an emotional eating
episode which then triggers potential
weight gain and seeing that weight gain
again then escalates the emotional
eating now while those two pounds could
be absolutely nothing more than like
bathroom habits what she ate that day
you know water retention hormones etc i
also have to note that your body is
going to fight weight loss it's going to
so even if you're doing all the same
things that you did to lose weight it's
not uncommon for weight to creep back on
now with all that said based on what
i've seen in this episode i want to
share some recommendations that i would
make to a client struggling with these
same behaviors and thought patterns
number one get rid of the scale i mean
the scale is just one tool in the
toolbox and it can be a powerful
motivation modulator but when the number
isn't favorable it's hard not to be
pulled down instead i would recommend
focusing on improvements to energy
levels digestion strength and endurance
i also know that in practice it's easier
said than done especially if you want to
lose weight or fat so if losing weight
or fat continues to be a goal then i
would rather see folks focusing on how
clothes make them feel rather than the
number on the scale which like i said is
just riddled with confounders number two
stand up to the diet donors in your life
i don't like the idea of relying on
other people to police our food choices
whether you know that's fans or people
she actually knows as we talked about in
my last episode i just think that that's
a setup for resentment down the road and
possibly a slippery slope for dangerous
behaviors if that validation is ever not
there but if people are going to make
fun of your choices or purposefully try
to sabotage them let them know how
you're feeling and if they still can't
respect your boundaries tell them to f
off like or at least just don't invite
them over to eat tip number three
continue to focus on nutritional
adequacy and my hunger crushing combos
not just like the lowest calorie or
lowest carb options you can get away
with if you enjoy eating low carb
totally fine you do you but i would at
least make sure you're not skimping out
on fiber in your meals and snacks which
will definitely help to boost up satiety
and regularity and tip number four do
not let yourself get too hungry before
dinner especially before dining out i
would never want anyone to not be able
to enjoy meals out with friends even if
we realistically know that those meals
are almost always going to be higher in
calories than those that are made at
home but focus on nutritional adequacy
and having meals and snacks equally
spaced throughout the day and don't
forget the pre-dinner hunger crushing
combo snack hack to help you arrive at
the meal with an appetite but not hungry
enough to eat
all the things so on that note that is
all that i have for you guys today if
you liked it please be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
with your thoughts and also what you'd
like to see me cover next subscribe to
the channel and i will see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]